Joe Biden has just been discovered to
have exchanged
29,000 emails with family and business
associates of the Biden family from his
vice president email account so Joe you
know Joe Biden had a number of
pseudonymous email accounts he came up
with all these pseudonyms to conduct the
particularly Shady business while he was
VP but among the this is according to
America First legal which does a great
job unveiling this kind of stuff
he used his VP email account to exchange
more than 29,000 emails with his son
Hunter with his brother Jim Biden with
their business groups which directly
contradicts claims that Biden made
during the 2020 campaign